my name is michel schwadzinger i work
for google as a software engineer i work
on the v8 team
which is now totally based in in munich
so v8 is developed in munich in the
engineering office and
the purpose of this talk is basically
twofold one is performance of course
we are all talking about performance but
the second point is the memory footprint
that all the performance optimizations
introduce
and um so i want to give it a different
spin from all the other talks that have
been given about v8
and see how we can get both of best
worlds so
great performance and low memory
footprint
so before i head off into that
first one slide basic overview of how v8
works and a
kind of a reminder of what you might
have already heard
so the main thing there are a few things
at google that we know to be true and
one of those things is
fast is better than slow so obviously
that's the main driving force for v8
we want to be the fastest javascript
engine out there
how do we try to achieve that so there
are a few
ingredients to that one would be
inline caching which allows us to access
properties of objects fast
because that's the main thing that all
javascript
applications do manipulate objects axis
properties
then as we heard in the previous talk
optimizing compiler
to really kick ass at the hot methods
and also another important ingredient
an efficient garbage collector and we
actually have a new gc
that's an incremental low pass garbage
collector
it's uh generational and
we try to get the pos the post pause
times as low as possible
by basically interleaving mutator work
so work that your application has to do
with garbage collection work
slicing these up and interleaving it so
that you can make
progress with garbage collection as well
as progress with your application
and a lot of other ingrediences we mix
those up and steer them well
and hopefully get high performance
characteristics in our engine
so we got speed awesome
but what else did we get with that
imagine you bought the new car and you
know it has a
pretty damn engine in there and you want
to take it out for a quick drive
and suddenly you find yourself in here
so
you look around and see all the other
cars and start thinking about
whoa hang on wait a second what is the
footprint of all of that
in your car you might be worried about
carbon footprint
if you're talking about javascript
engines you might be worried about
memory footprint
so before i dive off into the memory
footprint
first of all how would you optimize a
javascript application
the most important thing first of all is
to find the actual hotspots find
what is important for your application
performance wise that would be functions
that are are
worth being optimized because they're
executed often frequently a lot of times
memory wise that would be finding
objects
that dominate the heap that are
omnipresent in the heap
and that live long or that have a bad
memory layout
but once you've found the actual object
that's causing a problem
you need to understand why it's actually
causing a problem so
without understanding the actual problem
there is no way you can fix it
and then you fix it and
the last item is really just that fixing
it
so here is my very personal
very unscientific opinion of how much
time you need to invest into these steps
um so fixing it is really just that if
you understood the problem
getting rid of it should be easy
this talk is mainly going to focus about
understanding the problem at hand
and since it's fixing so since fixing is
so easy we'll also do that
okay so let's look at a few examples and
the three examples that i want to
present here are
objects like tracking array
representation and
execution context we will look
at three examples in depth and discuss a
few best practices how to
improve hot code around those
optimizations the first one will be
about
how are objects represented in memory
second one how are
areas represented in memory and the
third one how is your actual
execution environment of some function
represented in memory
okay let's dive into that so the first
thing objects like trekking
most of you might have already seen this
example the famous point example and how
would this point be represented in
memory
so please stick with me i'm going to
give it a different spin
this time with the addition of slack
tracking
so let's go through that application
step by step
and i promised i tried to
do this without assembler so i just have
fancy graphics explaining it
no assembler code i hope that's okay so
the first thing when we
execute that constructor is we actually
allocate the object in memory
you probably know that we have a hidden
class system behind all of that because
javascript in itself is a very loosely
typed language and
to really optimize for for certain
objects we need to have a
more precise type system behind it so we
we
invent our own types and call them
hidden classes
and we just give that new object a
little bit of slack so
in this graphic that would be four slots
that are available
directly in the object so there is no
indirection going on here you don't have
a packing store
where the actual content will be stored
it's directly in the object that also
serves as an
identity so let's add the first property
that would be
x we we added
and since we now modified the object
layout
we actually added a new property that
can be accessed
we also need to transition the hidden
class so it's now a new type in our type
system
and we remember that transition so
whenever we start from the first hidden
class
add x we'll go to the next hidden class
and as i mentioned before we store the
value
directly in the object so accessing it
is
just taking it's just loading one word
out of the object knowing direction
second step obvious add a new property
transition the hidden class again so
if you think of this um transition chain
or transition tree that you get on the
on the on the right hand side
um you can imagine what would happen if
you suddenly
add these properties in a different
order you would end up with a
different hidden class in the end so
that would be one point to avoid
um now let's repeat that with the for
loop down there so we get two objects
that both have
x and y and now we have this
fancy modification of the object that
comes right
after the constructor so how would we
deal with that so every second object
gets a set
property okay we can just add that no
problem
we still have slack in the object so
both objects are actually over allocated
we allocated too much memory for those
objects
and at some point when we have enough of
these objects
we decide to basically freeze the
the transition tree we say okay your
application has allocated enough objects
they are probably going to look like
this most of the time
so we're gonna freeze that state and say
okay those are the
um those are the classes the hidden
classes that you're gonna work with
now we actually wanna get rid of the
slack that we have at the end of each
object
and we can do that we just shrink the
objects
the problem is every point that you
instantiate with the point constructor
can either have two or three properties
and we don't know
how many so we need to keep around at
least
three slacks in in each newly allocated
object
and that means for half of the object we
waste that memory it's really wasted
so that's probably bad if that's a hot
object
meaning you have like a million of those
objects floating around in memory
that would be pretty bad so
we hopefully understood the problem now
how can we fix it well
fixing it is easy just use two
constructors meaning
you come up with two transition trees or
transition chains
and um both maps can be optimized for
their object size
so that fix is pretty easy and
either so i left the implementation of
those two constructors 0.1.2 and 0.3 out
you can either implement them directly
which means you have some duplication in
there
you could use some frameworks that are
out there like the
prototype framework
all types of inheritance you could even
use
you from within point three you could
call the point two constructor by using
point two call this and pass the
arguments through that would all work
the object layout would still look like
this the important thing is
use two different constructors tell the
vm that you actually are
dealing with two different types here
so i said we should measure it
i hacked this pattern into a ray tracer
which um
deals with about 600 points 600 000
points
and up to three wasted
slack slots in the in the objects and
keeps them alive in memory
and that's the improvement that you get
out of there
and those are 40 percent so
40 percent less memory that your
application consumes
which is quite okay i guess
um so now since
if you don't wanted to uh to to to think
through all of this every time and and
come up with the actual representation
that that
uh your objects is gonna be in memory
i will give you a few best practices
that you can follow
and that will hopefully allow you to
write applications that are both
extremely fast and slick memory
consumption wise
so first thing is try to initialize all
properties in the constructor
and as i mentioned before add all the
properties in the same order because
otherwise that would screw up our hidden
classes
and avoid object layout modification
after the fact so after the constructor
has come up with
the initial object layout
now this might sound like i'm taking
away
a little bit of freedom from the from
the
from the expressiveness that you have in
in javascript
but let me tell you a story about that
so i went into this
i went to this pub recently and at the
entry they had this sign
and it said this pub serves food
that is good cheap
and served fast you can choose three
you can choose two and
that's kind of that kind of reminded me
of this so you have
performance speed on the one hand then
you have
memory footprint on the other hand and
then you have the expressive power
or the freedom that javascript gives you
and i'm not claiming that those three
are
actually all the time mutually exclusive
but knowing about those
three points in the triangle
understanding it and knowing where you
are located in this
triangle might help you to write better
applications
okay so let's move on to the second
example area representation
so far we only talked about name
properties
now it's going to be about index
properties so
again we have something that is used as
a constructor or that
used as a factory to instantiate arrays
and
again it's a hot method because it's
executed several times
thereby the area it produces
is a hot object and might
make up a bulk of your heap
so the first thing we do here is we
actually
instantiate a new array for arrays we
want to have
an object that represents its identity
that would be the
small box at the top that also stores
the length so how many elements
how many index properties do you
actually have in that array and we over
reserve the backing store again
so we again have like four entries that
we can fill up after the fact without
resizing the actual banking store
so we can do that we add
in index property with the name zero
we add the index property with the name
one and
now we add another property that's
actually
a double value so that backing store
is in intended to store integers
or small integers actually so now that
we store a double into it
we actually want to have an efficient
representation of that backing store
efficient performance wise that means we
actually want to unbox those doubles
in that backing store that means we have
to change the layout of that backing
store
and we do that it's now taking
64-bit words and
that backing store is able to store
doubles directly in them so as you see
the 0.5 is stored directly into that
backing store
that means we have to convert all the
previous small
integers into actual doubles now that
conversion takes a bit of time
takes additional memory but that doesn't
matter that much because the old one
is no longer referenced and can be
garbage collected
so and next we store
an object and the true value in that
backing store that's represented as an
object
and that means the work we just did was
bogus we have to go back to the old
representation again 32-bit
and now we actually need to box the 0.5
the double value
which again means we have wasted a few
cycles by converting back and forth
allocated a new banking store again and
collected about a bunch of hidden class
transitions that
track those transitions so
if we generate lots of these arrays
it's gonna get gonna have a bad
performance
and also you see there are a lot of
backing stores which actually contain
the same
the same values so
that doesn't look very efficient neither
performance wise nor memory wise
so what would be a possible fix of that
possible fix would be to not use this
strange construct at all
but use an array literal
with an array literal v8 can basically
infer the optimal representation of the
backing store
allocate that right away and the most
important thing we can
share the backing store between the
arrays and
those backing store is now becoming a
copy on right backing store that's what
the cow should indicate
that means we can share the banking
store as long as you don't modify any
anything that's stored in it as soon as
you start writing to one of those
backing stores it will be copied and
modified
so all the other areas will still share
the packing store
and this change should give you a
performance boost
and a memory boost awesome right you can
have
best of both worlds
and again there are a few easy things to
follow here
which should allow you to avoid this
kind of trap
the most obvious one is if you use the
eric
if you're able to use area literals try
to use ariel literals they're really
awesome we can generate highly optimized
code for it
and we can immediately come up with
optimal representation in memory for it
pre-allocate small arrays to the correct
size so that basically means
pass if you know the size ahead of time
pass it to the constructor
and most importantly try to use
arrays for to store only one kind of
element in it
so especially try to avoid mixing
object values with
double or integer values
okay the last thing is about the
execution
context so
javascript is a functional language and
what that means is that
on the on one hand you can have
so one thing is functions are first
class objects so that means
you can pass them around as in variables
you can have nested functions inside
each other and they have a proper
lexical scoping so that means
the inner function can reference any
variable
that's declared in the outside function
so what does this mean in this example
we have
an auto function make closure with two
variables in it large value small value
so obviously
large value is going to be the bumpy one
we have
two two inner functions in it and
closure and both reference some of the
outer values
and then we call this function make
closure several times
so what does this actually mean
since the inner functions reference
variables from the outer functions we
need to preserve
that execution environment in some way
so it needs it needs to be stored in
memory
and the way we do that is we have a
context object
that's actually in heap object that's
allocated on the heap
and we put the values that are
basically going to survive the execution
of the outer function
in there so arguments can be context
allocated in this case the size
argument because it's used by a nested
function
so should the nested function init
escape that outer closure
we need to preserve that execution
environment
same thing applies for variables they
can also be context allocated they are
also going to be put into that context
and as i said this context is going to
be referenced by the nested functions so
this context is the execution context
the execution environment for those
nested functions so they're gonna keep
it alive until
as long as they itself survive
um so what does that mean
if one of those functions dies like the
init function
it's going to go away but the context is
still alive
because it's referenced by the closure
function which escaped
the outer function and the large value
can be some
huge object some huge array which is
basically
the bloat in your application and you
want to get rid of that
so how would you fix that
easiest solution just get rid of that
large value
context allocated variable
move it into the uh into the inner
function that's the easiest way thereby
you got rid of the context allocated
variable
and the closure function will no longer
keep alive the bloat
so again i wanted to measure this and
measuring this giving a percentage here
is just
is just pointless basically most of the
application developers will just
consider this to be
a leak so um
understanding this construct
understanding this
way that the va context allocates
variables
and that functions can keep alive whole
contexts
might allow you to fix severe memory
memory leaks in your application
so here are again the basic best
practices
the first and most important thing is
you should be aware of
context allocated variables so you
should be aware that
these things exist and
ensure that hot closures so basically
closures that you generate often
have a have a small outer context and
move variables as deep as possible into
the nested functions
thereby avoiding those leaks
so we just got rid of
all the bloat and um hopefully this
allows you to
um to write applications that
that that don't introduce memory bloat
that are performant after all
and hopefully this might also apply to
other virtual machines
because um
so all the all the examples i gave are
highly targeted for for v8
so they they discussed how how v8
represents these objects in memory
but i guess the same
the same optimizations could be applied
in other vms i cannot judge that
but it should allow you to drive all of
your engines safely
and have a free highway like this
so with that i want to thank you very
much for
for listening in if
so i hope i could convey some of the
basic concepts how
v8 come comes up with
representations of objects in memory and
how to avoid some booby traps that are
hidden in there
not intentionally if you want to know
more either
ask me now because we have yeah actually
we have lots of time
and you can also find me in the
during the breaks at the google booth or
contact me directly
so if you have questions shoot
i've got a question about hidden classes
so you said
you would prefer if people would
create instance variables in
constructors yes does that also
work if you do something like object dot
prototype dot
variable name equals something or other
um so if you
if you store an and property on the on
the prototype of an object that means
it's
actually going to be stored in a
different object
that's referenced through the
dunder proto field as i learned
yesterday and
so whenever we access that property we
have to follow
that down the property field and then
access that object
but the representation of that object
same rules apply there
so how you come up with that
representation
is again follows the same rules
so
the prototype object that you use for
for this object is going to be shared
among different
among several objects so most of the
time the prototype objects aren't hot in
a sense that they
that several of them exist on the heap
they are just hot
because they are used often so they
should have a
performant implementation performance
memory representation
but if you waste some space in there
it's probably not
that important
thanks so i was i want i wanted the
example where you had a two different
representation so at this point here and
usually if this object is hot it's used
very often and yep and
v8 is much much faster if it's
monomorphic so my general advice would
be to say only
have one cast that has three fields and
if you don't use the z
field just for undefined now you will be
just faster and i mean it's
32 bits okay yes it weighs a little bit
of space yeah compared to the speed
do you obviously understand the problem
at hand i hope i could
teach that underlying general underlying
problem to more people
but knowing about this trade-off either
waste space
or have a monomorphic object brings you
forward and
a huge step and then the second question
was um this inner inner functions so
when you have a
nested function inside your i mean the
init function for instance
um you have to run through the whole
function to
to see what variables are captured or in
the nested function
why not also see if the init function
itself is actually uh
captured itself or leaves the scope so
in this case it's called from within
the constructor so you know it's not
going to capture any variable
yeah you would need so i mean in this
example you could just
say okay i see it right i look at all
the code and see it
but it requires escape analysis because
you need to find out whether that
function escapes or not
but you're really looking if if if
something is kind of a
i mean you you have to see if large
value is inside the init function so you
just
keep tracking the init too so it doesn't
seem that difficult
it just i mean if it if in it is used in
a non-calling function context
okay then just say we need to capture
everything in there but
that doesn't look that difficult it's
not really a difficult analysis
no it's not maybe it's not a difficult
analysis but the problem is you need
some
optimizing compiler for that and the
layout of the context you need to get
them right the first
time so when you have when you
didn't optimize the function yet or
otherwise
transition that context layout somehow
if you optimize a function because you
already created some
instances of the of the function object
they escaped into your heap they're
floating around
and now you decide to optimize this
whole
mess this whole make closure thing and
you come up with more with a better
representation
but there is already the bad
representation out there so
if we could if we crankshaft everything
then we would be smarter about that but
then startup performance would suck
so again classic trade-off
um one more quite detailed question you
were talking about
allocating and assigning all the
properties in the constructors so that
you can presumably
uh allocate the precise amount of space
in the object itself
um how accurate can you be in that can
you can you really determine precisely
how much to allocate or will you
um ever have to spill to the so separate
array
um the perfect scenario for
from a vm implementer point of view is
if you just have simple this assignments
in the constructor so if your
constructor looks like
this is this is this is we just look at
that code see
during parse time so no optimizing
compiler we see the layout
there in the code and just boom come up
with the optimal representation
and when we inline when we optimize the
function boom inline that
know how it looks like so that's the
optimal way but that takes
away a lot of freedom from javascript
developers i was asking about the more
complicated case where you might have
some branching or whatever which
you know yeah by creating a different
layout the
the one solution we we use is this
object select tracking so we over
allocate all the time like this and
after we have observed a
fixed amount of allocations we shrink
the objects and
seal their size if you want so that
gives us the most flexibility even if
you have non-simple
constructors great i think that'll be it
for now
give a hand to michael thank you